six months ago saref antal emigrated
from Germany to Israel despite the
country's high cost of living and
volatile political situation she has
Jewish roots and because she never
really felt at home in Germany she
decided to move to Israel just like tens
of thousands of other Jews from around
the world do each year so Zara quit her
job in Berlin packed her banks and
started over in Israel now she devotes
her time to researching her family's
past
[Applause]
Zarah has been attending daily Hebrew
classes each morning for four months now
I can speak the language quite well
without an accent but you need to know
the words to be able to read them it's a
bit of a challenge I think it will take
several months or years before I can
speak the language like an Israeli
people from 16 different countries
attend the language classes hailing from
places like the US Venezuela and Ukraine
most are Jews the Israeli state covers
their tuition but learning Hebrew is a
formidable challenge five months are
nowhere near enough you need more time
than that you'll learn the basics to
help you communicate and to help you
understand some things but you need
better language skills to work in Israel
Sarah knows that of course back in
Berlin she had a permanent job as a
journalist now she lives from her
savings and does a bit of freelance
reporting she wants to be able to work
as a German language journalist she
found an apartment in central Jerusalem
near her language school but the rent is
almost doubled the cost of a similar
small apartment in Berlin
Zarah is still furnishing her place I
think I was a bit too comfortable for my
age in Germany I had it all really a job
at partner and apartment but I wasn't
happy
[ __ ] favicon is clueless his room was
fun this is a great adventure and it's
just for me I don't have to think about
anyone else
it's a liberating feeling along with her
new life in Israel Zara has started
writing a book about her family history
these are falls from yad vashem
the document yen they help document my
grandfather's Holocaust Odyssey looking
at them as depressing they stayed over
and over that he was a Jew that the
reason for his arrest is that he was a
Jew it's really depressing to read this
but it makes me appreciate being in
Israel even more for me father it means
a lot to be among the majority now I'm
just one among many Jews here these
files were the first things are turned
up in her research into her family
history much more research lies ahead
her grandparents were originally from
Prague Zara is great aunt once told her
what her ancestors endured during the
Holocaust
she's made enquiries and today she's
visiting the archives of Yad Vashem
Holocaust Memorial to see what the
archivist has turned up she's waited a
long time for this moment at the
archives our Amit's Esther Stan it was
found some documents relating to genres
family Stan discovered files with many
details about Sarah's family history
including the family's deportation to
Auschwitz concentration camp she points
out details of the transport including
the names of food of Cydonia Tomas and
Ella gap the file documents the last
time they were all together
Zara's grandfather Thomas survived
Auschwitz he was an important influence
on her as a child
Zara spots one of his inmate IDs he had
nothing because he came from Auschwitz
no she's they took from him everything
and he came like you see but he his
signature is here for the very first
time in saunas life she sees a picture
of her great-grandfather who loved he
was murdered in Auschwitz and it's the
very first time she gets to watch Yad
Vashem video testimonies one features
her great aunt Helga before passing away
Helga told Zara about the horrific
things she experienced in the Holocaust
things she had never told anyone before
Zara is the only family member left to
keep the memory alive it's a huge
responsibility it's hard to describe
what I'm feeling now that I know all
this I'm deeply moved because I finally
seen a photo of my great-grandfather and
seen his handwriting that gives me a
better sense of his personality I feel
like I know him better
but I'm also somewhat overwhelmed it's a
lot to take in
Alice if we have minds of you
after visiting the archives Zara
explores Yad Vashem Holocaust History
Museum knowing what her family members
suffered has left a lasting impression
on her soon she'll return to Yad Vashem
archives to find out more about her
family's past but for now she's also
busy living her new life in Jerusalem
it's Friday Zahra is at Jerusalem's
Mahana Yehuda market
it's almost Shabbat and she's buying
groceries for the evening dinner things
are quite expensive in Israel it's
definitely not cheap you've got to be
careful what you spend your money on but
you can also get some things that are
fresh and a bit cheaper than elsewhere
on Friday afternoons she typically hangs
out with her friends today she's meeting
her buddy our glazier
that one of the markets cafes
you want to bring something yeah misery
never been to build it you know what
back there like in Berlin you head like
the incidents where you felt like
anti-semitism against you into the
street somewhere
actually there's a lot every time you
take a cab and the topic comes in anyway
like I want to go to the center but for
example people are like Oh synagogue are
you Jewish and then they come from the
being Jewish to Israel and like start
talking about that the Jews around the
world that like Israelis are suppressing
everybody you ever and anywhere when you
win the bra I don't go with the Cuba in
my head so but I've never felt like
someone treating me
The Situation's not that easy
people tend to sometimes just you know
like run away so then you come here yeah
I think I really want to support Israel
I think it needs support
I'm not afraid so of course I know we
have problems in this country it's so
important that we have this Jewish state
I want one Jew state for us and the
others can live day life
Zara wants to take the initiative and do
something for a new homeland for example
by going into politics but for now she's
focused on her new book in 2014 she
visited the Auschwitz concentration camp
Memorial and discovered her
great-grandmother's suitcase I'd never
seen it before and we didn't have any
photos of it I've asked myself how come
it caught my eye in that huge room full
of suitcases I found it pretty quickly
once we arrived that was a really
special moment against cancer cause a
moment discovering the suitcase
convinced her to go through with her
long time plan to move to Israel
as the Sun sets on Friday Israel's
weekend the Shabbat begins so far it's
been a bit tricky integrating into
Israeli society and finding a
congregation but it's nice to see
everything closed down for Shabbat it
gets so quiet it's great for winding
down and celebrating this day Zahra
hasn't yet found a congregation to
celebrate Shabbat with at the synagogue
so she spends the evening with a British
friend from her Hebrew class and her
Israeli partner letting the candles is
an important Shabbat custom pocket
Adonai Eloheinu melech ha-olam
ejaculation ovum it's what a fitzy mine
only had weaknesses Shabbat amen Zara
likes observing Jewish traditions and
once her future children to do so too
it's a way of honoring her ancestors she
feels a strong connection to Israel I
actually feel very home in Israel I felt
home here before this is where I came
here I already have like daily routine
and daily business I found new friends
we have Shabbat together we do other
stuff so I'm really happy with my
decision mmm a perfect start to building
a new life in Israel
[Music]